how to say out like a Canadian so recent
got a comment on my YouTube channel from
Ghostface 89/100 she wrote in to say I
think the voice-over guy is Canadian
I'll go back to said that I am and she
responded with the way you say out gave
it away
the Canadian accent is so cute I don't
mean that in a condescending way there's
just something about it that's very
likable now I know that Canadians have a
lot of different words for things that
Americans might not be used to we like
to say loony and Tunie and garburator
kerfuffle homo milk and double double
Timmy's Tim's and Timmy hos serviette a
and toque click doc bacon and the states
washroom pop and chinook poutine
beavertail pencil crayon but I've never
heard anybody say I have an accent when
I say the word out
so I'm wondering how do Americans say
out I thought to find the answer I would
turn to Godzilla
take us offline sambar listen to me you
need to get out of there
Sanju listen to me you need to get out
of there was that good sound you listen
to me you need to get out of there was
that close so if you want to tell me how
Americans say out differently than
Canadians I maybe give your own example
leave a comment below I love to hear
from you believe this is a little off
ball video but if you guys want more
entrepreneur videos subscribe to the
channel you'll see more just like it
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you soon sign up for the newsletter
for more believe
you